the official Las Vegas Victims Fund
created to help victims of the mass
shooting in the city has now raised more
than 14 million dollars that total is
expected to rise before the cutoff date
for donations on January 31st Mike
castor is one of the around 500 people
hurt when the gunman opened fire on the
Country Music Festival 58 people were
killed Adriana Diaz met castor days
after the massacre and has been
following his progress ever since it was
a heartfelt homecoming for Mike aster
the latest stop on his long road to
recovery he's back home in Southern
California for the first time since the
night this photo was taken at a Country
Music Festival in Las Vegas pastor was
shot in the back his girlfriend tawny
temple risked her life to get him to the
hospital we met them two days later Mike
if Tonya wasn't there well I did take a
bullet for her so she was she was you
pay me back doctor said it was too
dangerous to remove the shrapnel lodged
in his spine leaving him paralyzed from
the waist down but caster's a fighter
for the last eight weeks recovery has
been his full-time job at Craig Hospital
a rehab center in Denver at 41 he has to
relearn what used to be second nature
you never think of all the things that
you took for granted you know they were
so easy no you know going to the
bathroom or just sitting in a chair are
you angry or frustrated that you're in
this position I mean I go through some
times where you know I get angry but
it's not gonna change anything
I just gotta kind of like take it how it
is do you still think about that night
no we haven't really gone back to it or
watched much news we kind of just been
just focus on rehab and getting home I'm
moving forward moving forward exactly
he's still the same my English temple
but her life and job on hold to be with
him he'd do it for me and her beat
what's been the hardest part
you know like seeing on our bad days
like we have like that's tough but at
the same time it's like I don't we don't
dwell it's just a bump in the road we
can solve amazing features I mean that's
what that's what we look forward to now
they're navigating life in a new way
everything from boarding a plane to
getting in a car with special hand
controls casters family has a GoFundMe
page to help pay for his recovery
a new wheelchair accessible home and car
what are you most looking forward to
about going home just mean back seeing
her dogs or roommates my family you know
my dog he's only home for a few days
before he goes back to Denver for
outpatient therapy and again temple will
be by his side she saved me she's my
hair oh what's that face man I don't
look at it as that I look at it like we
saved each other for CBS this morning
Adriana Diaz Palm Springs California
give us that update it's good to see
Mike and Tony listen they have to get
used to a new normal but they have each
other you can tell you're all pulling
for you both yeah I love how the dogs
greet you like dogs give you such
unconditional love it really is